hey everybody we're live
on the comma youtube starting comma hack
everyone's here
say hi to youtube are you live streaming
yes
got some cool
announcements to make at the start of
the hackathon right harold got some cool
announcements
some great announcements so
figured we'd stream it for everybody who
can't
make it here today
some very cool
hacky announcements today
so uh yeah we're all out here in the
main room here
ci's currently failing oh gimbal's
failing too
gimbal why
there we go we're back
all right
this is a scene
just scene do you want to announce
why you're here
um here for the hackathon yes
yep
that's pretty much it
the rest is uh
is a secret for now
all right we're ready here we go we're
starting thank you so much for coming to
our uh 2021
hackathon
um
george have a little intro and then
we'll have some pizza
all right
oh i didn't prepare a speech
um
how many all have you all common devices
right
how many of you all brought your common
device
all right all right a good number good
number
um
yeah so
[Music]
uh
you you did the zoom what are we uh do
we have project ideas what's our
who here represents the youth by the way
who would say they represent the youth
kids there's one all right we got three
new that's what we need
[Music]
cool
so yeah we have a lot of open pilot uh
related projects uh to work on
but you know comma is a lot more uh than
just a
we're not a self-driving car company i
mean our mission is to solve
self-driving cars but the reason we
chose that mission is because
self-driving cars i still believe and
believed at the beginning are the best
applied ai problem in the world
all right
our goal is to solve
ai in general and how do you know when
you've solved ai it's a good question
um how do you know when you understand a
radio
well there's a there's this paper it's
called could a biologist understand a
radio
and it doesn't bode well for the
biologist right they're like classifying
the different organs of the radio
they're doing like radio dissections you
know you understand the radio and you
can build a radio and we will know that
we understand a human once we can build
a
human um
so of course you know
when we think we're building a
self-driving car we're not building a
car because a self-driving car is not a
car a self-driving car is a car plus an
uber driver
we work with existing cars we're trying
to build an uber driver
all right
um
so you know some fun
announcements and maybe some project
ideas this here is a comma body
they're going to be available for sale
next year but you guys can can see them
early on uh it's just a comma three uh
being able to control this body uh so
you can think maybe some hackathon ideas
related to this unfortunately we only
have one common body right now but you
know a lot of the software there was
some discussion about making some like
face software that display some eyes
maybe using the driver monitoring model
to be able to watch people
um you know just sort of just sort of
fun stuff
uh you know we have access to
you know the team that basically built
all this stuff
so uh
you know questions about comic crime
that we've never taken time to document
right like some common security features
some unlock your car doors kind of stuff
this is all like doable all right we
have can fd captures from red pandas
adding can fd to cabana we have a list
of
hackathon ideas i'm going to pull it up
on this yeah all right
stuff on the tv um
for you know the common body the one
that we actually sell will be a little
more slimmed down this with a pole on
top of it uh so you know this is this
stuff is the future but we also have an
announcement
uh you guys remember at the last
hackathon was anyone at the last
hackathon
wow
uh vivec was the last hack thought um
we announced comma 10k which is our
segnet dataset uh at this hackathon
we're announcing depth 10k um which
comma 10k has a picture
and segmentation labels depth 10k is
great because it's completely
unsupervised we don't need people to
annotate anything it's a
really high quality
uh
you know images captured from comma
threes ten thousand and there's like
their image triples right so they're
images one taken at zero one taking a
fifty milliseconds one taken at a
hundred milliseconds
um so it's like just three consecutive
images from the really high quality
comma three camera uh we've gotten great
results with some unsupervised depth
nets so it's just a fun data set to play
with
um and we are open sourcing that
well unfortunately i can't stand here
you all can't crowd around my computer
maybe if i open source it we can bring
it up on there
i'm gonna click the button to open
source.com guy and uh maybe someone else
talk while i'm doing that
harold say something
yeah i'm just trying to pull up the list
of all the hackathon projects
so that if people want some ideas
they can get inspiration from that i
think some cool ideas would be to maybe
run some games on the common three
uh
[Music]
hopefully we have much bigger office
uh we raised 10 million dollars
uh so uh
raising money is not an accomplishment
let me explain you know people are like
oh you got money oh that's a good thing
no i paid with my soul
well that's what you pay with right
you know
all right so i'm in debt uh i'm a debt
to some some mafia guys
we got 10 million dollars so we're gonna
have some money to buy uh
an office um
big data center you know big models tons
of data everything faster this is def
10k here as you can see those are like
image triples from the dataset
but yeah that's open source look you
know i have two issues on the project
like those images i didn't even look
through all 10 000 images so like you
know buyer beware there could be
pornography probably not but you want to
check them um there's also a whole lot
of just junk images in there so like you
know even if someone wants to throw up a
pull request just removing like the the
you know 100 of those images that are
just like staring at a wall right
curation of that data set the camera
intrinsics are there so you can do all
sorts of cool things with that you know
get like yolo nets up running like how
many how many people are in depth 10k
how many license plates can you supply
no
um
data set four ideas what other hackathon
ideas we got what do we got on the board
oh there's a bunch of things on here
we've got uh well i just wrote down play
games another thing somebody mentioned
was a see-through comma three can you
make the screen track your face
and show what's on the other side of the
device
um
running the simulator
on your laptop oh display port on the
comma three if somebody could do that
that'd be really cool you know every
common three and i spent like a dollar
fifty on this per device right that's
not much until you're building you know
10 000 devices and you're like wow
that's just 15 grand that was just for a
feature that nobody's ever going to use
but maybe we can you know somebody can
use it and that goes well in conjunction
with playing the games because then you
can play the games full screen
um you guys know the common three is
running full on you've bought 220 or
four
how many people have a couple three
how about a two
i've got a freon
[Music]
uh designs
oh that needs designs wow
we can get some designs
um
any other projects we want to talk about
on here at the deep
um
what are we talking about so
far oh uh i mean i guess we should just
talk about like
we brought people here to do cool
projects but
if you like spend a day or two and you
think you're not getting that much done
you want to fall back to some practical
projects we have big lists for you um so
i don't know
think ambitious today and then tomorrow
you know you can sleep on it and think
whether
you want to go practical or do something
cool
um you have to need any of our hardware
uh we have hardware available for loan
um somebody who wants to write like
right hand or fuzzy test you know take
two red pandas connect them together so
you can get some can of d messages going
between them
yeah
that's pretty much it what else we ought
pizza
yeah
and if anyone has questions
[Applause]
i mean there's plenty of coma employees
around if you guys have questions about
any other project or want some
inspiration or anything like that so
feel free
to bug us
yeah
and uh we'll be streaming the
the results in
two days on sunday we'll be restricting
the presentations
i mean yeah they know about it
congratulations everybody here i'm very
happy you know i'm a really big fan of
things that are meritocratic uh things
that have like like you know
like just wasn't the last hackathon
unfortunately we did where it's like you
emailed in and like we kind of like
looked over stuff and it was very
subjective this was a ctf right so the
people you see here today are not just
you know they're winners they're people
who did well in our ctf which required
real skill and uh you know to see that
is a lot cooler than raising money right
like skills skills skills cool
so yeah uh i expect much better things
for this hackathon in the last icon of
course because you guys have proven
yourself your test of scale r is high
the bar is high
ah you know hey look anything that gets
done right like anything that gets done
don is better than perfect uh move fast
and great things uh what else would mark
zuckerberg say
we rebrand your company the better
what should we rebrand right i
personally anybody who figures out what
a real use for the common body is
because like we're selling these things
they're going to be sold next year it's
a common three on a stick that balances
right
when we give it to you what does it do
it balances it will stand there and
balance right if you guys can like
figure out how to like wow this could
actually be useful for something we're
interested right um it also makes
development on these things more
accessible right like a lot of people
can't buy common devices because they
don't support cars or maybe they don't
have a car at all
calm body is for people
uh so yeah enough about that uh let's
eat pizza i really like those garlic
nuts they're very
delicious or something i think a lot
want to do one of your um yeah
i think like maybe we know people from
vr
yeah we're done streaming bye everybody
we'll see you sunday for the
presentations you missed out do better
than ctf next time that's right
bye youtube
[Music]